I know one thing that I know nothing
Socrates I like this phrase when I first
heard it's stuck with me there is an
expectation when asked to give a lecture
that one will impart some wisdom so the
wisdom is this I know one thing as I
know nothing
I think Emmys a very odd case actually I
think she's got them I mean probably the
most unusual CV of all the writers in
the series unbelievably successful is
play right in their own right I think
with playwrights who have school
themselves in the theatre there's an
obviously a huge versatility with
dialogue they tend to be very good with
characters and then a very successful
career in TV with with you know very
much able to kind of juggle the needs of
a long longer series or the one off when
I'm pitching or having a an idea pitch
to me I try to keep blank it's because
I'm waiting for why I should write this
idea why I should spend the next 2-3
often more years writing and rewriting
and shaping and cutting and trying to
find one's way through a mental maze of
possibilities and the truth is I often
start a script still not knowing for me
this is often the best way to be it's
the carrot this state the desire to find
something when one is often grappling
around in the dark and it can come in
many different ways and at many
different times sometimes you get a hint
of it in the research a sense of what it
might be
why is it that certain ideas make me go
I'm interested in that there's something
about that and it's it's a sort of
instinctive starting point for me is
there's just something in it that I go I
don't know why but I'm drawn to it and
in the same way I have to listen to that
critical voice because sometimes you can
go and I love that sounds great and your
instincts not really there about it and
those are always the projects that never
work for me so it's very difficult to
define it as one thing and it can
sometimes be because I'm a fully
interrogated one element of something oh
and the irony is when you do a film for
example about sex addiction suddenly you
get sent lots of ideas about sex
addiction I mean no one sort of or you
know you do something about the first
world war and everyone says will you do
another film but professor wall you know
and actually it's often the last thing
you want to do this [ __ ] of light that
I try to find that I mentally stick on
my laptop
it's my running partner my torch in the
dark often it will be at the core of
what my screenplay will be about it is
the start of gaining knowledge of
knowing something however brief and
affirms to me that out of nothing there
is always something outside of the facts
outside of what is visible I call it the
dog whistle that I have trained my ear
to hear she's just an incredibly
original writer I think she gets very
very taken up with different situations
and and you know can take something
that's a kind of true life tragedy
something that's a very very
contemporary very risque story and
something that's a real period piece you
know kind of delving into the depths of
the BBC and you know kind of how how
early television worked I think she
found it very very hard to sort of find
the through line in all her work Maya
des coming often be based on strange
nuances that go on you know so it can be
being in a cafe and noticing a mother
with her daughter and hearing their
fight and rustling realizing you know
the mother's incredibly jealous of the
daughter because she's growing more
beautiful than she is and why that's
interesting well how do I feel about
beauty and age and how terrifying would
it be to be a woman who was beautiful
and relied on her looks her whole life
and then suddenly she starts to Oh what
about decay go to we're all decaying
the cities you know and I will build
from that so that would be my starting
point and in a way that was sort of how
shame came about that riffing on a
thought and a theme with Steve or I'll
be sent a book that will just kick me in
the guts or a you know a newspaper
cutting that make me go what this has to
be written about so it'll just it has to
be a compulsion there's something in it
that there is a compulsion and probably
on a really selfish narcissistic level
it's because somewhere in it relates
back to me you know
I start at the beginning I always write
linear I can never write an ending if I
haven't found out where it starts
openings are important to me the first
player wrote took me two years and I
think it was because I wrote and rewrote
the first page maybe a hundred times I
now think if that play is my
apprenticeship then I did use a
typewriter and I would yank the PayPal's
paper out theatrically toss it in a ball
and throw it in the bin and start again
isn't that the way writers do it in the
films I now see it was the mental
warm-up the place I was starting to
piece together all the other moments and
that the reworking and working is just
my way of finding my way in it's where I
tried to bring formed the chaos most of
my writing the writing journey is a
process of this finding form to chaos
because as much so try to stay in the
state of nothing pretty quickly my mind
is racing well all the people I have met
books I've read films I've watched
interviews I have seen the opening is
when I'm finally alone when it's just me
well the laptop and me the newsreel
today the board the public for too long
give me this opportunity and I'll prove
it thank you
of course I'll need an assistant two
minutes mr. line but may I say one more
thing you haven't seen my best yet
the ability to change to shape-shift is
key in writing drama that doesn't mean
one has to concede on every point the
joy for me as a writer is that despite
the fact I spend most of my life
on my own in a room eating too much
chocolate and drinking too much tea
eventually they let me out into the
world and then I get to work with
directors and actors brilliant actors
and genius do Peas and designers and
producers who listen and make your icing
and one young woman in particular has
caught the eye of a certain leading man
actor Adam larae engagement looks set to
the Honorable Ruth Elms daughter of Lord
Elms of traveling of eligible young
bachelor I like a relinquish enough
control I like the handing over of
control but because I choose very
carefully how I work with you know and
so as you know and III if I don't think
it's going to work I withdraw in some
way so and I think it is an act of faith
so so that's what you know that's part
of the process but it is hard I think
when you you love a script and you know
the material and you know your story
very well it's hard sometimes if you if
you feel that that's being changed and
it will inherently get changed and and
so I totally respect writers who are
like that because they perhaps just have
a stronger sense of their vision whereas
mine always feels quite fluid but at its
heart the kind of navigational compass
is always you know it's the dog-whistle
that I talk about it's the sense that
there is something in there that that
excited me and I believe is the thing
that triggers a director to be drawn to
it and an actor to be drawn to it
I have been lucky I've been very very
lucky it's amongst this ensemble where
the work is really made I never know if
I'm the Builder or the architect the
role shifts all the time but what I have
come to conclude is that the script is
the muse
for producer director actor DOP and
designer it is the point of inspiration
that everyone wants must think of as
their own as a producer I know how
fundamentally important it is to get a
good story and a great idea and that
that story and that idea have to have
great believable characters who have
living palpable breathing emotions that
people will relate to and believe in and
you know scripted action sequences or
dramas that that you can shoot in and
worth shooting and actually that all
comes from the head of a screenwriter
they have to start it they have to
deliver on it it's only on the basis of
that screenplay that you're going to
attract a good cast and a good director
so we really owe a huge amount to them
and and that they're working with
screenwriters is part of the process
that I personally enjoy most handing
over the script delivering it it's a bit
like giving birth to a baby sometimes an
ugly bothersome baby that you have loved
and carried and cared for and fed for
nine months but now it is born and like
having children the shop is to discover
that you give the most vulnerable part
of yourselves legs and you put it out
there and very quickly you what should
adopt it you watch it become someone
else's hopefully and eventually an
audience who will take it in as one of
their own and you just have to trust
that you have done enough that it
carries enough of your genes that it
won't grow up and become something
completely separate from its point of
conception completely alien from its
point I think you have to be careful
sometimes because you can lose your
voice or you can allow your voice to be
so misguided also you know you the work
does move beyond you and that's
essential but I think also what you're
trying to do is you're trying to contain
the kind of organizing principle of what
you were trying to say and the kind of
pot of themes and the strength of the
narrative and you hope that that will
carry through and that will become the
inspirational point for director
production lino designer actor when I
first approached about writing a film
about Margaret Thatcher there was a very
good script in place but at the time the
small screen had suddenly been inundated
with some very brilliant films covering
her early years the felt revolt from
crisis and beyond then I read an article
written by Carol Thatcher about her
mother describing what it was like to be
with someone who now lives in an other
world suddenly the life of Margaret
Thatcher became the life of a very
particular every woman a powerful
revered and often reviled former head of
state it would not only be a study of
power but a love of loss of power the
ability of the mind to play tricks and
rewind one's life would provide a
structure a form for the chaos of a rich
and powerful life you know I think I
grew to really have a great connection
for the character of Margaret Thatcher
you know I personally my high politics I
think most people in the arts are
probably you know didn't adhere to her
politics and I didn't I grew up in the
80s so obviously I that was part you
know a huge part of my upbringing I
approaches there would approach any
other subject I'm a writer of fiction
that is my job to find something beyond
the real truth in artifice
responsibility is an interesting one you
know I've never I've never written about
someone who's still alive and it is an
interesting experience and so it was
very important to me to see that film as
something other and to see it as a sort
of as I say a study of power and loss of
power and really connecting with the
public profile of someone but also not
being able to ignore the elephant in the
room that was being spoken about in the
press and that we all know about even if
I know nothing the film must know
something and this is the third thing
I've come to understand
I have to find the [ __ ] of light I have
to find my opening my way in and
somewhere I have to find what I feel the
film is about even if it is never used
even if it is never screened I have to
write it place it somewhere in the
thoughts and words of the character
enclose it in a scene embed it in the
heart of a film the one thing I know I
know nothing until I know something this
is that something too much much too much
butter I like that milks gone up yeah 49
P a pint
good grief never economize as we can
always sell the car or take in paying
guests watch out she's on the prowl
eat your egg goodness there you are yes
here we are
I do lots and lots of drafts but
probably I have between 3 and 5 moments
or drafts where I go where am I so I
would say there's the first draft
there's the third draft there's the
fifth draft and then there's the seventh
draft and that's when I do I kind of go
is this still my film where have I gone
is this you know and along the way I'll
have done various tweaks and changes and
rewrites and pulled out and change the
perspective gone back on you know read
eventually then actors read it you know
and it goes on it builds but there there
is a very simple process and actually
there is a sort of reoccurring process
and for me it's I you know I take spend
a long time thinking about something and
then I digest material and then I write
it quite a tight treatment now which is
almost like you're watching the film and
then I throw down my first draft and
then I give it out my favorite film
script has never got made and it's still
a complete mystery to me because I think
it's my best piece and I still think why
does that never got my you just and it's
just one of those films grits that
haven't so so and so there are scripts
right where I am bemused and heartbroken
but most of the time I really I like
brutality I like someone saying lights
just doesn't work
because it's really really hot and if
they're you know the worst the worst is
silence the worst response you can get
to them and that I would say that's when
it breaks my heart is when you'll
deliver something and you'll get what
you'll get is yeah no no it's good it's
good will yeah we're just waiting to
gather our notes and that's dead you
might say that films over that's never
going to get made
shame came out of a meeting with the
director and artist Steve McQueen it's
interesting to work with an artist I
don't consider myself one an artist for
me as someone who holds on to the single
vision perhaps that is why film is a
director's medium the director is the
one who has to juggle all the balls from
conception to set and then edit and
beyond the ringmaster and I suppose I
believe the artist that does not mean I
don't believe that as a writer I can't
be part of creating a piece of art I see
works of art all the timing film what
should have been a blind date lasting no
longer than an hour set up by our mutual
agents last in three we both have
children we both have partners we you
know we both there were sort of similar
rhythms to our life I guess and I guess
we talked about our 20s and what that
had been liking what's he like now going
out into the world and internet-dating
and does that drive to meet to fall in
love does that change when you're
married and you're settled and uh no I
don't think it does
but but but also what happens when that
never settles when you're constantly
striving to and and that and I'd witness
something recently had witnessed
somebody who I was quite close to really
coming to the end of their life and the
thing that really shocked me when I
watched them was that they only had a
few hours to live and it was still
important to them that they got the
attention of the nurse and I'm talking
about the sexual attack the flirt and I
thought good on you you know you're in
the last few hours of your life and you
still want to get the attention this and
that was really the starting point when
I said to see if I said I wanted to I'd
like to write about a man who's still
looking for that kind of attention right
to his dying day and so we talked around
there and that's really how Brandon was
born focusing on the life of a man bound
by his own compulsive sexual behavior
the research took me into a world I
thought I knew something about sex we
all do it or hopefully do it at some
point in our lives over the weeks months
we worked on this film together Steve
and I met people who had worked with sex
addicts who all who were themselves
recovering or battling with addictive
sexual behavior this was a world where I
found more than a dog whistle there was
a constant surprising underscore of tiny
behaviors and almost invisible
transactions that flooded my senses and
made me realize that this was a world
that affected us all I think the
collaboration of Steve McQueen is a
really interesting one I mean this is
the second time that he's collaborated
with a very successful playwright and I
before I spoke with a view about shame
had really believed this was Steve's
film but talking to her you realize
absolutely that is not the case it was
it was a complete you know a
collaboration in two halves we met you
notice I live in London Steelers
announcer so we would meet in New York
and I went to Belize no actually really
simply we couldn't get anyone to talk to
us in the UK because you know addiction
sex addiction isn't really recognized
and obviously you know there are there
are lots of theories about it and but
you know America loves to talk so you
could really get people to talk out
there so in America what you know I was
able to we were both able to just plug
into a whole group out there and talk to
people and so we would talk and you know
the first time we went we just met lots
of in you know we met a lot of
predominately guys and we found the
addiction thing was slightly different
with women it was it was odd oddly it
was much more about romance and love and
fantasy it was a very different thing
but but with the men it was much purer
and terrible generalization was I'm sure
that's not true but of everybody but it
was of this experience and and we would
we would always kind of arrive and we'd
eat though I mean the joke that the the
restaurant seems really interesting
because we would constantly talking that
can't be someone going you know that's
great no yeah rock is fine yet you know
we'd so that food thing was very we'd
eat and we talked and we'd meet people
and then we'd write and the first shame
was was Steve's idea and Steve's title
because we would often meet people and
then we go we've got to get our plane
and we get on a taxi and the journey to
JFK I think is about 35 40 minutes of
traffic and often the feet we would just
not be able to talk it's very odd and
there'd be this sort of wait and steve
woods just said to me one day at shame
the kind of real catalyst for the film
was not off the story was not you
the sex edition addiction or you know
kind of any of the male aspects of of
the the story that came out in the end
but actually was New York it was being
in New York and the kind of you know
looking at I guess for both of them
being in a kind of an outsider in a big
kind of you know very very very urban
space most of that film was was written
in the standard and of course the
standard becomes a very big you know
location for the actual film you know
the song with Carey Mulligan singing his
lair and the boom bar upstairs and the
big sort of sex seduction scene is in
the is probably virtually in the room
that I work and I wrote in so um yeah it
helped it felt very organic the whole
experience the final film is in fact the
last 40 pages of a hundred page script
we threw away the first 60 pretty early
on on which was someone who rewrites and
rewrites both frustrating and liberating
it then became a process of distilling
and distilling perhaps this is also
because I work with a visual artist who
trusted in the image and that less is
more and even if it's no longer spoken
it will be heard it demanded that I
trust in the power of film I think what
she did was Shane was extraordinary I
think that it you know it you said that
it was a kind of very male story I
actually don't think that's true I think
that when I think of shame I don't think
of Michael Fassbender's character I
think of Karim elegans I you know that's
that that's the heart of the film for me
and you know how she carried herself how
she sings how she looks how she dies you
know I think that's what you what you
really are drawn to yeah you're very
curious always
full-life me aya i don't know why anyone
wants marriage people would want to get
married especially nowadays I mean this
yeah I don't see the point in
relationships
it doesn't seem realistic you still
believe in it in relationships yes it
has to matter we have to matter to one
another otherwise why we here why are
you here
the food's supposed to be great no no no
no I know I'm not saying it like that I
mean and it just means you one person
for the rest of your life I mean it's I
mean you know you come to restaurants
you see a couples sitting together and
they don't even speak to one brother
they they don't have anything to say
they don't have anything probably don't
have to speak to their collective or
they're just born without mother you
come to a restaurant you order the same
thing every night because what because
you love it because you can't get enough
of it will you tell everyone you know
the service is just the way you want it
and you can't get the taste out of your
head so you go the next night and the
next night and and that's it
that's the only place you can eat for
the rest of your life that's your
longest relationship
um exactly that's you can pour for
months you have to commit you actually
give it a shot I did for four months
when I was preparing for this I found
some notes I wrote for Shane very early
on because before I even started on the
script
they made me smile because I think I
hope that the [ __ ] of light that
motivated me to write Shane the essence
of why I write remains shame shame
should be like a bag of sand we should
conceal it for as long as we can
married single works on Wall Street we
see a normal day in the man's life
slowly unpeeling all seems normal but
slowly and surely we sense that
something is wrong he visits the
bathroom a normal out but with
repetition we start to feel unsettled
suspicious he works late most nights the
glow of the screen in his face he takes
the same route home from work looks at
the same landmarks the same tiny moments
as he's build through the first 20
minutes we see that this is the start of
some ritual the behavior an addict his
addiction to sex fade in/fade out to
capture the sense of time moving on this
can be within the course of the day to
extend our understanding slowly reveal
the tiny details of this man's flight
paths from work to home from day to
night all and to show a sense of time
passing over a longer period seducing
the audience take it slowly but here's a
man alone in a toilet cubicle doing what
men do alone until someone unlocks the
door I hope the film carries all of this
like a dog whistle
inaudible but calling one to attention
provoking one to hear something beyond
words beyond language open but in the
state of knowing nothing's I right to
keep myself sane I write I write if I
don't write I get ill I but I write
because I found a thing that probably
gives me the most pleasure and how lucky
was I that I found that in my late teens
you know because most people spend their
whole life trying to work out well that
so and I write I write to make sense of
the world and and probably to
communicate I write because I really
want other people to know when I suppose
actually one of the biggest things is I
want to write and tell other people that
they're not alone because I spend my
whole time observing things and thinking
cause I know that I can understand that
all or even observing things in people
that I haven't felt but thought that's
true that's gosh that must be hard or so
I often write because I care about I
care about a kind of democratic level I
care that we are all somehow united and
that sounds a bit worthy but I suppose
it is also one of the motivations for
all right
you